demain donc qui va démarrer c'est Marine
Le Pen qui a gagné le tirage au sort
elle va démarrer et c'est un atout pour
elle on sait qu'elle s'est beaucoup
recentrée là sur le la dernière fois
j'avais démarré en 2017
ah c'est plus alors on va vérifier on va
vérifier
il regarde alors non mais et donc c'est
un avantage de démarrer oui c'est un
avantage et puis elle a un autre atout
qui est le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron elle
manquera pas d'utiliser les attaques
qu'elle a préparé contre le bilan
d'Emmanuel Macron comme des atouts à son
service même si elle aura à coeur de pas
être trop agressif puisque elle pense
que c'est ce qu'il l'a écornée en 2017
c'est un match retour c'est un duel pour
l'instant aucun duel télévisé même si
c'est un rendez-vous important il y en a
eu depuis 74 sauf en 2002 donc c'est un
rendez-vous qui a attendu par les
Français mais aucun n'a véritablement
changé le rapport de force électorale
aucun n'a changé
n'a pas fait changer d'avis les Français
c'est au fond comme un peu un match de
foot les Français ils y vont avec leur
maillots ils ont leur équipe et il y a
peu de chance
exactement ça accentue
à moi alors moi je vous dis moi je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous moi
je me rappelle quand en
2007 non non non pas du tout 2012 2012
Sarkozy c'était très serré et je et on
est je suis sorti du débat j'ai dit à
tout le monde c'est cuit ça sera sécu
pour Sarkozy sera Hollande le Président
c'est sûr franchement là c'est une des
seules fois vraiment ou on s'est dit
vraiment ça s'est joué ça s'est joué au
débat parce qu'on pensait que Nicolas
Sarkozy elle explosé et en fait françois
Hollande s'est révélé et c'est vrai
qu'il aille préparer
président et c'est vrai que moi ce que
j'avais senti à l'époque et je je
l'avais dit à un moment quand je l'avais
croisé je dirais que j'avais Nicolas
Sarkozy sortait de 5 ans euh voilà de de
de soutien Kenna donc c'est 5 ans de
règne et c'est vrai que derrière on l'a
senti fatigué et c'est vrai que un
moment je me suis dit un moment tu le tu
le coupes tu lui dis on n'est pas tu es
pas venu ici pour réciter ta poésie
voilà non mais c'est vrai tu vois on
n'est pas là voilà les journalistes se
regarder à quel moment c'est vrai qu'on
avait l'impression réalité il était donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a très peu de
surprises à part à ce moment là c'est
vrai que Ségolène Royal Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2007 on s'était un petit peu jouer
aussi Marine Le Pen Emmanuel Macron 2017
aussi là vous pensez aussi que ça
changera pas grand chose mais là on est
dans le scénario que vous évoquez
c'est-à-dire que on est dans une marche
d'erreur même si la dynamique s'accentue
en faveur d'Emmanuel Macron ces derniers
jours il y a quand même une possibilité
pour Marine Le Pen de montrer ce qu'elle
n'a pas su faire lors du dernier débat
c'est-à-dire qu'elle était à la hauteur
de la fonction et qu'elle est un égal à
Emmanuel Macron et là alors
2017 c'est là donc elle redémarre oui
alors c'est extrêmement tendu entre les
deux équipes rien ne se passe bien il
s'engue globalement sur tout par exemple
Marine Le Pen en 2017 reproche au
réalisateur de l'avoir trop filmé le
réalisateur c'est extra qui le
réalisateur
voilà et chaque Didier froly c'est le
réalisateur de du débat et il aura
derrière lui deux assistants
réalisateurs un pour la team Macron un
pour la team Marine Le Pen pour du côté
de chez Marine Le Pen elle hésite encore
entre un garçon qui s'appelle Laurent
jacobelli ou Philippe balarque un ancien
journaliste de LCI visiblement si
jacobelli qui tient la corde et du côté
de Macron ce serait Jérôme revent
d'accord très bien et Marine Le Pen a
exigé que quand Emmanuel Macron elle a
obtenu satisfaction que quand Emmanuel
Macron parle on ne la filme que dans le
regard pas de plan généraux parce qu'en
2017 on l'avait vu triturer ses fiches
et donc elle estimait que le réalisateur
lui avait joué un mauvais tour donc là
chacun a donné ses exigences et c'est
carrément un couteau tiret alors ce sera
soit un espace de 1000 mètres carrés la
climatisation est réglée à 19 degrés ça
c'est ils ont choisi tous les deux c'est
du 9 degrés moi si je faisais le débat
ça serait 24 déjà le gars je me flingue
c'est quoi il arrive
19 degrés donc c'est un entre les
candidats il n'y a pas de clim
individuel il y aura plus d'un groupe
électrogène de secours voilà il y aura
en plus un groupe électrogène de secours
un ingénieur clim il y a 23 caméras
de plus qu'en 2017
et un espace de 2,5 m² de 5,5 m entre
chaque candidat et merci
pour pas qu'ils se foutent sur la gueule
et 4 mètres entre les candidats et les
journalistes ça veut dire qu'on peut
péter tranquille
personne ne le sait oui Le Parisien
révélé ce matin qui a eu un échange dans
les coulisses de face à Baba sur ce
débat entre Marine Le Pen et Marlène
Schiappa elle lui aurait confié en
coulisses qu'elle regrettait d'avoir
trop parler d'Emmanuel Macron dans le
débat 2017 et qu'elle comptait plus
parler de son programme et du coup
Marlène Schiappa a remis une note à
Emmanuel Macron pour l'informer de ça
voilà c'est rien dans les cuisses de
façon
face à vous Cyril en disant je regrette
d'avoir trop parlé du programme de mon
du candidat concurrent c'est-à-dire
Emmanuel Macron et pas assez de mon
programme donc à mon avis elle va tirer
les alors il y a eu plein de tirages au
sort il y a eu trois tirages au sort le
premier pour désigner l'ordre de la
prise de parole c'est Marine Le Pen donc
il parlera en premier il y a un deuxième
tirage au sort pour désigner qui
s'assoit ou c'est Emmanuel Macron qui se
rappelle c'est à gauche de l'écran et
Marine Le Pen qui serait passé à droite
c'était l'inverse en 2017 et le
troisième pour le choix des Loges
Emmanuel Macron aura des choco BN et
Marine Le Pen
c'est vrai que c'est une petite
nouveauté aussi cette année Gilles
Bouleau seront debout pour le lancement
de l'émission C'est pour donner un peu
de dynamisme et moderniser un peu ce
débat c'est la première fois que ça
arrive d'accord
que les candidats mais au moment de la
conclusion c'est Emmanuel Macron qui va
débuter c'est à dire c'est Marine Le Pen
qui terminera ça ça peut être important
ils ont même discuté de la couleur du
décor le beige parce que c'est important
pour les tenues après ça va jusque là
dans le moindre détail il paraît que
Emmanuel Macron a choisi un costume en
tafta non non mais au départ ça devait
être un décor virtuel de l'Élysée avec
des deux bâtiments neutres et ça a été
récusé par les deux candidats ils ont
préféré
parce que on peut comparer ça un match
de foot capital et il y a pas les
joueurs qui décident de toutes les
conditions et là de décider les moindres
détails jusqu'à la couleur jusqu'à la
température et Machin tu as envie de
dire mec va jouer ton match là c'est
maintenant il faut y aller
d'accord vous pouvez imaginer que
le moindre détail
sur une image juste un neutralité
absolue le moindre plan qui montre
quelqu'un un visage embarrassé ça peut
faire perdre l'élection c'est normal tu
te rends compte de l'élection n'est pas
totalement joué qui va noter chacun des
plantes pour dire
lui attendre plan large elle a tant de
plan large le temps de plan serré tant
de plan serré tant de plantes pour que
ça soit à égalité parfaite alors il
paraît que Marine Le Pen c'est
énormément entraîné qu'elle a pris un
coach un mec qui ressemblerait Emmanuel
enfin qui serait dans le même voilà qui
qui parle loin un peu comme Emmanuel
Macron voilà comme ça pour lui faire un
ping-pong c'est vrai alors c'est un
exercice classique non non elle sait
vraiment entraînée et elle a
nécessairement cherché quelqu'un qui
sera capable de lui répondre comme le
président de la République lui répondra
et c'est la même chose en face le
président a nécessairement des notes qui
lui sont remis sur les attaques
potentielles Macron n'a pas moins
travaillé que Marine Le Pen ce serait un
piège ce serait un piège comme Nicolas
Sarkozy a été piégé par manque de
préparation en mé moment où on
sous-estimant la capacité de François
Hollande à maîtriser ce débat je trouve
globalement que ils innovent peu il faut
quand même savoir que la plupart du
dispositif qui est imaginé là il est
inspiré de Sky imaginé Serge Moatti en
81 sur la base des erreurs commises en
74 par François Mitterrand franchement
il serait peut-être temps à l'heure de
Tik Tok et d'autres réseaux sociaux de
proposer autre chose aux Français par
ailleurs c'est un match retour qui
risque d'être déceptif si les candidats
eux-mêmes ne laissent pas une marge de
manœuvre au réalisateur dont c'est le
métier mettre la réalisation sous la
supervision de gens dont ça n'est pas le
métier c'est un truc un peu étrange même
quand ils sont vos militants ça c'est
comme si on mettait des chroniqueurs on
les faisait parler télé qui n'y
connaissait rien
des candidats elle est intéressante
aussi pour parler de ce débat parce que
du côté de Macron on dit c'est pas une
obsession en gros on nous fait
comprendre qu'il a l'air entre
guillemets voilà complètement
[Musique]
c'est de dire on se prépare on y va on
est prêt et il y a une revanche à
prendre donc c'est vraiment deux
communications totalement différentes
autour du débat alors on a on a le
plateau du débat on va revoir le plateau
regardez qui a été dévoilé
on va aller là où vont se situer demain
soir Marine Le Pen et Emmanuel Macron je
peux vous révéler que Emmanuel Macron
sera assis ici Marine Le Pen en face de
lui à cette place effectivement vous
voyez vous allez le découvrir qui a bien
effectivement un écart entre les deux
candidats il partage pas la même table
cette année 2 mètres 50 effectivement et
puis les journalistes Léa Salamé Gilles
Bouleau un petit peu en contrebas à 4
mètres précisément tout est
effectivement vraiment codifié alors il
y a plein de gens qui me disent moi je
vous dis voilà je vous brûlé la question
qui ne comprennent pas pourquoi le débat
est diffusé sur TF1 et sur France 2 il y
a plein de gens qui me disent dont Loïc
n'ont pas droit il me dit pourquoi ce
n'est pas diffusé que sur France 2 le
service public ils ne comprennent pas ça
on sait historique mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a plein de gens qui m'ont posé cette
question c'est sa sécurité pourquoi ça
serait pas sur le service public il dit
on paye la redevance c'est pour voir ça
justement pourquoi c'est diffusé sur
deux chaînes en même temps
tradition est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça c'est c'est quand même non mais
c'est vrai c'est c'est une bonne
question
vous n'avez pas la réponse
on peut pas laisser passer une ambiance
comme ça
l'idée c'est de prendre les deux entre
guillemets la chaîne d'État et la chaîne
privée la plus puissante et donc voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on prend la chaîne
Youtube et la chaîne prix
pour toucher le plus grand nombre parce
qu'il y a plein de gens qui ne regardent
pas France 2 qui regarde très peu voir
mais je ne regarde pas j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] tu me mets tu me mets ma single
sur TF1 c'est aussi une question
d'équilibre politique il faut pas se
leurrer vous vous avez la la TF1 qui est
censé contrebalancer peut-être le
service public même si là c'est pas
évident mais voilà c'est une question
d'équilibre
lorsqu'on dit le service public ils sont
moins avec le président bizarrement que
TF1 mais dans l'historique il a été
moins bien traité jusque là il est passé
on peut quand même remarquer une drôle
de gueule ce plateau il est très vintage
c'est très peu soigné ce qui passe
derrière je trouve qu'ils ont des leçons
à attirer de ce qui se fait ailleurs
parce que on propose pas là un écran
enfin c'est pas pratique c'est la
tristesse absolue
les mecs on dirait une chaîne YouTube
sur l'économie franchement à un moment
on va voir Squeezie débarqué total